[Musik]
konkret ist es so dass in deutschland
etwa 23 bis 27 millionen weihnachtsbäume
jedes jahr in die stuben gezogen werden
und den größten marktanteil daran hat
die nordmanntanne hier die die
nordmanntanne ist halt wunderbar
gewachsen sie es schön ausladen die
abstände zwischen den sogenannten ast
köln das ist ja immer ein jahr das ist
der der jahres spross wenn es zu hoch
ist also spricht zu lange dann wird der
baumgartl ich aber der hier ist
wunderbar schön gleichmäßig gewachsen
der wind bestimmt jemanden der sich an
ihm erfreut
[Musik]
was die klimabilanz weihnachtsbaumes
verschlechtert ist der transport der
plastikbaum klingt auf den ersten moment
als alternative allerdings haben
wissenschaftler ausgerechnet dass die
co2 bilanz das plastik weihnachtsbaumes
sehr viel schlechter ist weil einfach
dort sehr viel energie in die produktion
gesteckt wird in das plastik da sind
teilweise auch eisenstreben in dem
ersten in dem stamm drin man hat also
ausgerechnet dass er mindestens 20 jahre
verwendet werden muss bis er also besser
ist als wenn man 20 jahre
echte bäume mit der baum kommt etwa wenn
er ausgegraben wird das
temperaturverhältnissen 5 bis 0 grad
sage ich mal jetzt kommt er in das
weihnachtszimmer wo man mindestens 20
grad herrschen wo die luft sehr viel
trockener ist selbst wenn man den baum
ordentlich gießt die meisten bäume
schaffen es nicht dann den wechsel in
den garten oder wieder an den waldrand
zu überleben und geht kaputt
bei weihnachtsbaumkulturen gibt es sehr
große unterschiede
es gibt einmal wirklich auch
hochproduktive weihnachtsbaumkulturen
dort wird entsprechend chemie eingesetzt
da werden selbst dann mittel wie das
privat eingesetzt aber wenn man halt in
dem sinne schauen will dass der baum
auch wirklich eine möglichst optimale
klimabilanz hat dann empfehlen wir als
schutzgemeinschaft deutscher wald immer
den baum beim örtlichen förster zu
schlagen das kann sehr viel spaß machen
gerade wenn man familie hat mit den
kindern in den wald zu ziehen mit der
axt mit der säge und sich den baum in
entsprechenden weihnachtsbaumkulturen
wie wir hier auch stehen auszusuchen
selber zu schlagen und am tor steht dann
der förster und ruft den entsprechenden
preis auf und dann zieht man den baum
gemeinsam nach hause
[Musik]